लुट नमस्कार आप सभी का स्वागत है जर्मन
सीखे हिंदी में क्या नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में
पिछली बार हमने मोड वर्कशीट आज हम चमन में
फ्यूचर टेंस कैसे बोलेंगे या भविष्य काल
कैसे बोलेंगे वह सी तो जरूर शुरू करें तो
सबसे पहले अगर आपकी मोड ऑन व कंसेप्ट ईयर
है तो भविष्य सीखना एकदम सिंपल है तो
इसीलिए मेरी आपसे रिक्वेस्ट है कि अगर
आपकी मोड ऑन और कंसेप्ट में कुछ भी डाउट
है तो फिर से एक बार वह जेल भर उसका
वीडियो देख लेना कुछ डाउट है तो वहां पर
क्लियर कर दीजिए कमैंट्स मैं आप अपने द
प्रॉब्लम लिख सकते हैं मैं उनके आंसर
क्लिक आया क्योंकि अगर आपका मोड ऑफ कर दिए
है तो आज हम सिर्फ एक वर्ग सीखने वाले हैं
वे जस्ट वांट टो लाइव विद और आपको भविष्य
काल फ्री मिलने वाला है
कि कैसे करते हैं हम अभी देखते हैं
है तो जो वर्णन सीखने वाले हैं भविष्य काल
के लिए वह व्वे इन थे वेस्टर्न और वह चलता
कैसे हैं अब हम देखेंगे
कि इस व्हेयर दो वे उस रेड्डी वीरवार व डन
वेलडन अभी तक ओके आई विल वेरी डर्टी कल
याद में में का यह चलेगा तीन दो मिर्च
सीरवी
की ही वृद्धि एब्रॉड ट्विंकल विल रिलेटिव
12345 एंटरटेनर
ए प्लेयर है जगह फिर से रूठ याद रखो
सेकेंड पोजीशन पर वेलंकर रूप आएगा वह
चलेगा इश्किया दूरियां हेयर के हिसाब से
जो मैं मर है वह में डाल वर्ग की तरह एंड
में जाएगा और इंफिनिटिव में रहेगा पांच
एग्जांपल्स लेते हैं तो आपको क्लियर हो
जाए
अच्छा ठीक है आई विल बी टीजर आई विल इट
मींस अ डिश वेल्डर की सा एडिसन
अरे यू विल ड्रिंक को दून विस अ को
प्रैक्टिकल ओके अ रखी विल प्ले क्रिकेट
ट्रॉफी क्रिकेट टीम अगले मिर्च अदरक
क्योंकि एब्रॉड वृक्ष बिल्कुल इस क्रिकेट
क्रिकेट क्रिकेट में हमने पिछले चीज करते
हैं पता है आपको पांच-पांच बजे आता हूं
हैं या फिर मैं कल आता हूं तो तू यार डू
समथिंग हंड्रेड परसेंट तब आप वर्तमान काल
का उपयोग भविष्य के लिए तरसते जर्मन सी
बहुत बार यह करते हैं स्पेशल जो नेटिव
स्पीकर्स जर्मन है वह अगर कोई चीज 100%
करने वाले हैं तो वह यूज इन प्रेजेंट टेंस
फ्यूचर टेंस बनाते हैं मतलब कल मैं
डेफिनेटली आने वाला हूं तो इसको मीडियम और
न इस को मारोगे या फिर करना मतलब पांच बजे
में क्रिकेट खेलूंगा खेलूंगा तो इस तिलक
क्रिकेट को शैंपू पर क्लियर है हमने इसको
मनोरञ्जन प्रेजेंट टेंस बनाकर फ्यूचर
बनाया आगे इन यह थोड़ा हाई लेवल है जब
आपको आदत हो जाएगी तब आप यह बनाओगे सिर्फ
मैंने आपको इसलिए बताया कि अगर आपने किसी
को यहां यह ऐसे सुना या कहीं पढ़ा तो आप
कंफ्यूज ना हो जाए
कि हम अपना बेसिक तू ही यूज करें
कि वह डाल फिर से डिवाइस करते हैं हमारा
वर्ग क्या है वह इन थिस वे डू ईयर्स एगो
DSC वीरवार को चलाएंगे बिल्कुल इस वेल्डर
क्रिकेट क्लब मुझे आशा है कि आपको आसानी
से समझ में आया होगा कोई डाउट हो तो आप
कमेंट में सकते हैं फिर मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट